22 year old Nina Fabel was killed in a
hit-and-run crash this week near Nellis
and Harmon and an 8 news now exclusive
as her family Grieves they're sharing
how this tragedy is now saving the lives
of so many others Madison Kimbrough
joins us live from Sunrise Hospital
tonight with this story Madison
this is where Nina was being treated
after being hit by a drunk driver on
Thursday now while she didn't survive
her memory will now live on in others
[Music]
I get a text message at about 10 30 at
night and it was somebody alerting us
that Nina was struck by a car there were
reports that Witnesses saw the vehicle
going more than 60 miles an hour tragedy
struck Thursday night when 22 year old
Nina Fabel was hit and killed by a drunk
driver this happening in the southeast
part of the valley on Nellis just north
of Harmon Avenue Nina who was pregnant
at the time of the incident had her own
personal struggles suffering from mental
illness and because of this was living
on the streets her family speaking
exclusively to 8 news now about her
struggles but acknowledging that while
Nina wasn't able to survive she is now
making it possible for life to continue
on for several others by donating her
organs we were looking at her brain
function which was not existent and
really had to sit and think what are we
going to do if our daughter is passing
and there's nothing that we can do about
that then we can give a gift of life and
we want that to be her last living life
Legacy Nina's father stating that in all
of this there is a sense of peace to
know she is no longer hurting it gives
you a feeling that again that she's not
going to be homeless again you know
she's not going to be abused she's not
going to be cold she's not going to be
hungry and that she's no longer going to
be on on the streets and that gives us a
better feeling about this situation
there are a total of eight organs
including Nina's heart and eyes that
will be donated to those in need a way
for Nina to live on through the bodies
of others Nina who was a mother is
survived by her 18 month old son whom
her family is taking care of and as for
the driver who hit her that suspect
37-year-old Oscar Pina was arrested at
his residence nearby and booked for DUI
and hit-and-run related charges
and her family shares with me that
instead of a funeral service they will
be hosting a memorial site near the
campsite that she frequented reporting
live near Sunrise Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now